la confrontation occident contre en
russie est désormais très clair et
moscou veut le faire savoir aussi nos
téléspectateurs sur internet ont calculé
que nos missiles sarm apprendre et 106
secondes pour frapper berlin 200
secondes pour paris et 2 100 de seconde
pour londres des missiles nucléaires qui
fonce à 25000 km heure et vladimir
poutine n'hésite pas à user de cette
surenchère taquet nous avons tous ces
outils n'ont personne d'autre ne peut se
vanter actuel membre nous n'allons pas
nous vanter nous allons les utiliser
s'il le faut et j'aimerais que tout le
monde le sache
c'est chaud alors emmanuel macron a eu
fait admire poutine aujourd'hui les deux
dirigeants se sont entretenus pendant
près de deux heures dix on a un extrait
regarde il a duré longtemps ce coup de
téléphone le premier depuis plus d'un
mois entre emmanuel macron à vladimir
poutine plus de deux heures c'est ça oui
absolument avec ce coup de fil ce coup
de téléphone emmanuel macron essaye de
renouer avec cette position d' équilibre
qu'il tient de parler bien évidemment au
nom de la france au nom également de
l'union européenne et par l'est aussi à
vladimir poutine avec une forme de
mandat donné par volodymyr hélène skip
c'est la position de la france une
position d' équilibre diplomatique
d'assumer de continuer à parler à
vladimir poutine mais pour autant c'est
vrai que l'actualité rend parfois
difficile
ce dialogue alors selon la communauté
une communiqué du kremlin vladimir
poutine aurait demandé à emmanuel macron
d'arrêter de fournir des armes à
l'ukraine voilà et
ceci explique cela c'est pour ça qu'il
ceci explique cela parce que cette
demande là en fait elle est la suite
logique de ce qu'on a montré juste avant
qui est une propagande que de la
communication pour intimider l'occident
et pour dire à l'occident regarder ce
qu'on peut faire si vous ne cédez pas à
nos demandes parce que stop sur le
terrain en ukraine ils prennent plus de
temps que prévu il s'agit maintenant
d'intimider et de dire voilà le missile
en question il sera livré qu'à l'automne
donc déjà on a un petit peu de temps que
c'est vraiment de la
propagande mais si on avait regardé ce
que nietzsche
mais koné mais
parfois les points
importants non mais c'est vrai mais
c'est bon c'est bon
et joueurs qui sont en bas oui les
joueurs ont surtout l'entendre jouer à
roland garros et vous avez le temps ou
encore me casser les couilles
mais ces scores
c'est une vraie question est énorme
maintenant pour tous les pays dont c'est
ce qui continue de fournir des armes
mais en risquant maintenant les menaces
nucléaires où est-ce qu'ils arrêtent de
faux nez de jusqu'à maintenant entre
guillemets l'europe était un petit peu
planqué s'est tournée va pas mais en
folie des armes et de l'argent qu'est ce
que va faire la france maintenant qu'est
ce que vont faire les pays d'europe face
à cette menace très sérieuse mais voilà
je serai macro accueillera bien bien mal
qu'est ce que tu as fais maintenant
nous fait
là pour ça
qu'est ce qu'il veut moi ça me fait peur
mais aussi
vous dites c'est de la communication
mais avec quelqu'un comme poutine
complètement irrationnelle en plus
malades ont dit qu'ils seraient traités
contre le cancer moi je suis désolé
quand il dit euh j'ai un arsenal
nucléaire il l'a moi j'ai peur je vous
le dis franchement j'ai peur et vous
avez voilà je je je suis très inquiet
oui oui bien sûr merci entendu la
dernière rumeur qui vient de sortir qui
est un de ses ex un des ex du kgb qui a
annoncé sur des télévisions russes mais
interdite qu' il serait bientôt opéré du
cerveau pour voilà et n'est donc oui et
donc il y aurait un homme un homme dont
on dit qu'il serait même plus dangereux
que poutine qui prendrait la relève le
temps alors là l'opération plus
mais qui est relayée c'est en automne
[Rires]
c'est juste ou non mais c'est ça c'est
pour vous qu'on a mis sur la tronche et
à ses cheveux à temps plein feux
d'artifice oui
c'est normal ça bon écoutez c'est pas
grave